he did not watch TV he disliked the news
he didn't listen the political radio he
didn't take sides he wasn't on the Left
he wasn't on the right
this week the Tea Party has treated this
tragedy in a reprehensible way they
claimed their rhetoric has nothing to do
with the shooting a lot of his political
philosophy was anti-government he had
picked up some of the extreme right
position it sprinkled with things
anti-government seeing the government as
an enemy what's been the role of talk
radio and fueling a heated language
wouldn't you be smiling too if you had
the entire Democrat Party running
interference for you I tried to inflame
the public on a daily basis 24 hours a
day seven days a week it does impact
people who may have a mental problem
bail in fact Sharron Angle and the red
got their first target Glenn Beck
himself has been responsible for three
authoritative fascination attempts this
year the Glenn Beck who obsesses nearly
as strangely as this mr. Loffler did
about gold and debts of books you
mentioned there's a theme that runs
through all of in particularly on Rand
book the idea of the individual against
the state they refused to stop calling
it a jobs killing health care repeal the
right wing loves the the go to rhetoric
for them is wouldn't it be fun to kill
the people we disagree with rather than
pointing fingers or assigning blame
let's use this occasion to expand our
moral imaginations